[Musique]
les eaux
c'est beau
cyrus amont phrase choc de voir s'il
travaille beaucoup
je trouve pas cette chose en son temps
des idées pour moi
qui ai envie de faire
un petit peu avec toi dans tes émissions
pour qu'on s'éclate en sans
plaisir moi je vais tenir le truc c'est
que il faut que tu fais plus récurrents
j'avais même si on se dise tu viens pour
moi si tu peux tous les jours lundi je
pense que tu vois le striker de letchis
tu doit rigoler quoi tu vas sortir des
toi tu dois
je te jure vos frères les gens y étaient
collées gens ne sont pas contents ils
adorent sur la vie de ma mère on aimait
les gens il faut offrir
c'est sûr ça non je m'appelle charge
des cas si on va
en
fait moi je suis vraiment mais vraiment
super fan de doc gynéco a bercé toute
mon enfant tout le monde adolescent pour
te dire maintenant je fais dix sont
aussi je mange musique je vis musique
je me suis toujours dis que tu pourrais
poser sur un ace son ce serait un truc
de malade à distance d'instruire avec
que des fois des trucs ça m'a déçu que
ça pourrait faire
savoir clairement cool mais
je crois que vous demander ton portable
accompli ce
geste
horrible crime a jamais rappelés fiori
demanderait mais rappelez moi j'étais
sur un projet de ouf avec garou le
général et non plus donc
c'est touche pas encore numéro à toi
oiseaux
tombant j'espère ok mais tu sais pas
trop si sékouba désole alain petit merci
à
ce que cyril il dit si j'étais en fait
tu dois la télé c'est quelque chose qui
va vite c'est ça s'arrête et me fait de
venir tous les jours 4 x 4 fois l'a dit
jeudi par
toi même toit s'appelle dans un truc toi
après les automatismes c'est ça quand
j'ai commencé avec ses rites après faire
pendant ce tu connais son humour c'est
sûr
je reviens juste parce que je suis en
fait ce thème avec ma cuisine c'est trop
une fan de coupe de toi regarde tu avec
doc gynéco a bossé ensemble bien
d'autres il est trop
con sourit
et me faire une petite danse à l'époque
sa cousine ouais si
[Musique]
tu veux pas lui faire
merci à manger un peu où tu veux pascal
ou non non c'est juste pour attirer son
attention de lâcher un peu de lest j'ai
senti qu'il avait fait du sport de
combat par exemple
passez moi je suis champion de jeu jouit
qui
certains j'ai les olé
[Musique]
c'est mon chien je te dirai rigole pas
dans l'émission ça je ne ris pas
tu cherches un mec à ma gauche
c'est comme important c'est à dire ah
ils me suivent dans mes délires si tu
nous lis tu galerie c'est à dire un truc
tu ma connerie tu vas sens et
[Musique]
ça c'est juste nous rejoindre avec soi
poteau et croit photo laurie
et quand je suis à côté puis j'aime bien
servir les autres j'aime rire ne pas me
mettre en avant
et c'est vrai ça ça c'est vrai j'étais
timide avec les maritimes ou dans la vie
d'antan vous êtes au niveau tous les
deux
fait pas mal
bref tu habites seul tout seul avec une
meuf ont fait de ce sport
des fois je fuis dès que ça devient trop
chaud je ne m'étais pas de ce monde
je
crois pas des marchandises enfant de toi
tu sais pas mon frère
ça s'est passé pour moi parce que je
vous hais les rangées
vous déranger
[Musique]
quand j'ai
vu qu'il a donnée je vous laisse la
serbie et s'est gardé de les déranger
j'ai voulu faire un courrier concernant
c'est bon c'est pas grave tiens donc on
va jouer
et voir ça à 6070
nous attentions font sa gamme gentil est
dangereux pour votre santé un peu de
musique avec sa frappe à 30 francs
[Rires]
tiger woods ma gueule et ça se vend tout
le monde il est gentil avec toi tu es
venu faire une photo de photos c'est bon
c'est pas la peine de faire l'euro ça
c'est pas la peine
tu viens tu viens de passer les gouttes
on voit
[Musique]
tout de suite tout le monde
souvent c'est pour beaucoup
la zone
richaud
stoxx
associé à quais du cap et les sourds ou
quoi [ __ ] tous les français je te
plaît super nourrir j'ai poussé savoir
alain defer tu veut leur enlever trois
s'il vous plaît monsieur arrêtez vous
les
voulez pas être content vous êtes
content ça va la télé tout ça c'est bon
c'est bon ou pas chaud avec du show au
danish quelque chose pour avis donnés du
show on a une équipe du show tout de
suite sais rien j'ai poussé
[Musique]
ce
qui se passe est assez souple un
monsieur moi c'est vous monsieur
écoutez moi qu'est ce qui s'est passé là
nous agresser messi pas
longtemps directeur d'accord j'ai eu une
nous agresser d'accord ok si vous
agressez sérieux
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon français
ça bien se fasse a réagi nicolas même
pas imaginer que
deux minutes on vous a posé une question
à vous de merde bavière avec un mytho
toi ça fait d'offres
spéciales
monsieur donc j'y vais comme chez nous
vous avez nous suivre aussi au
commissariat on sait qu'une bonne
position apple mathieu d'accord ça va
bien se passer s'arrêtera pas pour
longtemps par contre comme on rentre
dans une voiture de police on est obligé
de vous palpez bien sûr pour voir si
vous avez rien dangereux sur vous c'est
la procédure c'est pour tout le monde
pareil ok vous levez vous plaît monsieur
d'accord
dc dc dc comme on veut avancer mon jeu
comme je devais me noter moi c'est la
procédure on a désarmement parce qu'on a
énormément c'est comme ça
c'est toi qui tiens tiens ya par ici
question comme ça que ça questionne se
passe
92 de mocassins retour avec tous les
individus ont commis ce rien
ok
pour tout le monde c'est pareil
[Musique]
commissariat soir
pour moi c'est un autre monde
[Musique]
c'est trop la
série a commencé comme en fait
c'est un mythe où il est par terre puis
deux heures jambes culture pas
de
citer en train de déguster une escale au
bon moment
je l'aï senti passer
[Musique]
et vous êtes arrivé
précédé ofran chargée
vous allez voir laquelle
[Musique]
vous avez failli être auditionnés en
même temps sa chaleur
le meilleur
c'est une réplique de tony montana
[Applaudissements]
je crois que
je me suis dit je suis dans un film a
engrangé aussi si c'est vrai c'est un
film après c'est vrai j'ai rien compris
c'est vrai tu savais
non mais là c'est la réalité la
main sur deux va
juste faire un petit protocole qui est
habituel c'est connu ça trouvait déjà
des caméras qui sont là de gros ça va
gg n'est qu'au hockey
imma be bons joueurs ça suffit basta
soir
rappelle le docteur toi à 6,3 calme-toi
là maintenant une gestion je prenais la
cgt d'associations enquête sur maquette
à
ton tour assieds toi
qu'est-ce qui se passe mais si jeune et
cause pour une audition bonjour bonjour
ça y est vous
vous le menotter à la chasse j'ai
[Musique]
mal au coeur merde [ __ ]
s'il vous plaît vous pouvez rester
simplement à côté de ça le côté d'où il
n'y a pas de progrès sans l'homme je
reste là oui je sais très bien mais
heureusement l'autre c'est monsieur on
va prendre votre déposition ont juste
savoir ce qui s'est passé est ce que
vous êtes sous l'emprise de stupéfiants
auquel vous êtes sûr de ce que vous
dites certes ok donc qu'est ce qui s'est
passé
et bien
gérer parce qu'on va pas y passer la
nuit un repas que ça à foot quoi pardon
nous avions rendez vous avec cyril pour
cyril c'est monsieur hanouna peut-être
oui quelle gare de relations verrai avec
monsieur nenê est un ami intime c'est
quoi ici à une forme de respect pour lui
il est
vous savez qu'il a des démêlés avec la
justice en ce moment pardon d'accord bon
non quand on y est on sûr in on était
sur le plateau de tournage et on a s'est
rendu dans un restaurant à peine 500
mètres plus loin environ ouais de là on
a commencé à discuter rigoler un peu
c'est nous prendre pour des cons parce
que là tu tourne autour du pot nous on
s'en fout là tu vois on n'a pas que ça à
faire non des rentrées pas à cause de
vos histoires d'un pseudo stars là il y
avait deux personnes sur la table à la
table d'à côté qui nous ont qui vous ont
ils nous ont parfaitement reconnu
la première fois qu'on a les embrouilles
avec amina donc on aimerait bien savoir
qui c'est quoi comment et
et bien ils ont considéré qu'on leur
offre
sur un individu dans un restaurant
parisien selon nos informations à ça il
serait actuellement entendues dans les
bureaux de la police judiciaire et
d'écouter ses premières réactions
d'habitants les notaires des reines
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé s'est
passé hyper vite j'étais en train de
dîner avec une copine et là on avait
honte à brûler
j'ai mon gagne pain je retrouve comme ça
dégoûté
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
réellement dans les mains il ya eu des
tonnes de renverser
s'est déroulée cette altercation cette
bagarre vous nous entendez
on peut avoir des précisions sur ce qui
s'est passé ce soir
j'ai reconnu quelqu'un de loin
envoyer quelqu'un est content
mais est-ce que vous avez une idée de
qui a commencé qui a démarré si c'est
plutôt doc gynéco si c'est plutôt à
cyril hanouna si c'est plutôt les gens
qui se trouvaient avec eux on l'aurait
que ce soit doc gynéco qui portaient les
les premiers produits qui
violent
ok donc maintenant on va dire sur tout
ça donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
réellement couple visiblement fait ouaga
commencé c'est toi qui a tapé c'est ce
qu'ils disent
et bien
c'est assez difficile c'est quoi ce set
qui a monté ton qui a tapé est ce que
c'est vous ou est-ce que c'est monsieur
hanouna
personnes à taper ouais à personne at
avait donc vous êtes là vous êtes
descendus d'un arbre de noël c'est sain
plus ou moins
non si c'est pas monsieur hanouna c'est
vous un manque que ce soit le père noël
de tout à l'heure il ya eu beaucoup de
zigzags comme ça entre les gens ça va
bouger dans tous les sens mais il ya eu
aucune violence précise de coûts porter
les médias disent que c'est vous on le
connaît hanouna il est connu des
services et il l'a pas hélas pas vous
avez trois syllabes à quoi et si il a
pas quoi nous n'a hélas pas quoi
dites là
hélas pas quoi il n'a pas il a
simplement il ya eu simplement des des
gestes brusques ou ya quelqu'un qui l'a
poussé il n'est pas tombé tout seul le
gard non mais tu sais quoi à peine le
témoin faisons la confrontation
genre tu m'amènes le témoin moi je
demande qu à vous croire doté d'un père
saguenay ce
que vous essayez de personnes ou pas
ouais vous vous reconnaissez personnes
ça c'est sûr ok donc on vous écoute
monsieur du coup deux accès au
restaurant ben moi j'étais tranquille
avec un copain je reconnais à monsieur
gynéco je lui demande
des conseils et ils m'envoient chisu de
ma gueule mon pote il n'a pas apprécié
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais si la
saisie m'a saisi le bras
une vie claque
[Musique]
vous avez frappé vous reconnaissez ah
non jamais je bois nom n'a pas écouté ya
un mec qui est à l'hôpital avec de co2
paie t il n'y a pas eu de cours faut
arrêter de me prendre pour un cours là
haut tu me regarde toi je te parle il ya
eu des bousculades et la personne a
trébuché ouais c'est ça la glisser sur
une peau de banane ok d'accord soit avec
son
home super u là on vient chercher tu me
ramènes autres on lui ouais tu fais
sortir suis là et tu me ramènes l'autre
non mais pourquoi
mais non mais pourquoi non mais dites la
vérité à un moment il faut arrêter comme
ça alors c'est moi je n'ai aucun doute
il est protégé par les médias je le sais
il a déjà eu des démêlés que la justice
dit tout ouais
il est régulièrement ici un abonnement
et là sans badge d'entrée mais répondait
monsieur beau si vous voulez revient en
coopération immédiate demain matin non
alors écrivez la maintenance qui s'est
passé au tout début vous êtes arrivés
ils font quoi qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est que je n'y vois que s'ils sont
énervés je sais que si le maire venu il
venait le deuxième fois à la fin mais
non avec
nos services on veut les publics sont
euros contre 11 on veut l'épinglé
10150 la sauce et installe aussi mais
mon qui a tapé mais un mot j'en ai
ras-le-bol là je pense que c'est lui non
il n'y a pas de suspense et santé tuchan
celui-là tu m'amènes hanina bon vous
l'emmenez à l'hosto là allez-vous manana
monsieur gynéco tout on sait que c'est
un sale bâtard d'accord réagissez mais
réagissent y pensez vous que vous dites
que c'est une non on dit que c'est sûr
je crois je me sens mal et tu y as
évoqué d'ailleurs
c'est quoi c'est bon qu'est ce qui est
beau jeune homme honnête à la chaise
pourquoi pardon
[Musique]
attendue des chaussures
ouais
ça est passé maintenant vous savez quoi
je vais être très clair je vous aime pas
moi non mais c'est pas une scission du
groupe rémy non mais pourquoi je n'aime
pas il vous protège la vo de copains
les deux rôles où ils sont nuls au bd de
relou je sais pas ce que c'est des rôles
où monsieur hanouna chez sonas il est
passé à quoi il est comme ça je vous
demande qui a capté
[Musique]
c'est lui c'est lui qui la pousse à oui
vous ne dites rien donc c'est un parent
du coup voilà ce qu'en séparant du monde
et a poussé alors je sais que je suis
chez moi il va vous les mettez la
pression qui va tout à l'heure est ce
que vous êtes sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants à l'heure actuelle non non
juste non non mais vous à vous savez
qu'il ya des médias lambert vous savez
qu'il ya un désir vous écoutez moi s'il
vous plaît el badraoui c'est une
histoire nous faut pour rien
non mais sérieux monsieur gynéco qui
c'est qui a tapé
je me suis pas rendu compte mais avance
non mais vous vous rendez ou pas sur une
matière et
vous avez un problème de langage ou quoi
là c'est lui qui lui c'est pour nous ok
donc c'est vous
oui
[Applaudissements]
monsieur gynéco vous allez être déféré
au parquet demain matin on comprend
mieux vivre ses amis au coffre vous
verrez ce que je peux faire de plus
les clés pour un monsieur nous n'a la
démo noter
c'est moi qui allais
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
elle a mis en lumière
la langue a mérité de monter l'émotion
on jette dans se prend que des civils
hanouna la confirmation c'est le
ce geste là mais et la tête de bruno
gynéco quand il se dit mais il en train
de ballons qu'il est en train de passer
là et fois clément même à revoyant la
vidéo une seconde fois on est toujours
aussi ému par la loyauté de nos
candidats décrouvrir jamais vu mais je
suis choqué de mais c'est un vrai mais
j'ai envie
d'être
mais alors il faut dire qu'est ce ce
piège est un piège absolument incroyable
qui est un des plus chers de la
téléphonie et des sept derniers temps
que quarante comédiens y avait quarante
comédiens voiture de police camions de
police le restaurant le truand rihanna
voilà comment ça c'est un petit film
on le sait que c'est un bâtard
qu'est ce que vous en pensez quand vous
leur envoyez c'est extraordinaire moi
c'est l'émotion des visages successibles
de doc gynéco il marque l'incrédulité la
surprise effectivement la loyauté c'est
hallucinant quoi tout son visage vit au
rythme d'un commentaire sur le visage de
cyril hanouna
il est très très attrayant il arrete de
dire quand même alain il avait envie
d'être est il était très ému de voir que
l'inspectrice est extraordinaire
les audois il le faire tourner parce
qu'il est bon coup d'éclat l'heure c'est
vrai c'est vrai oui mais si vous voulez
c'est vraiment way une belle séquence ya
presse de l'émotion après ses larmes aux
yeux oui qu'on a envie de le serrer dans
nos bras en faire un vrai franchement on
va chanter sa région thies donc un vrai
gentil